hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to west of loathing ok
it's time to get on with the main story
whatever the hell the main story hits
cuz I haven't got a goddamn clue there's
been so many things to see there's
another one the humming cave like of
course I'm gonna go to the humming cave
how could I not go to the humming game
my doors open so I'm gonna go to the
humming cave ah we're all goddamn its
way up there better have some goddamn
cultists in here will your finger.this
Gary a strange noise for listening to
are you hearing kind of a quiet humming
sound yeah I hear it too
what is it what I think it's coming from
this game huh these rocks are weirdly
organized it's weird weird purple grass
seems a little weird here I mean I'm not
any sneaking gonna let you pass without
a struggle well that didn't hurt at all
so this electrified snake is gonna get
the [ __ ] beaten out of it but by poison
it yeah that wouldn't work right no way
to work crap you're getting the crap
kicked out of it no matter what it does
okay goodbye snake spleen snake liver
the spleen is the seed of the fire
humors or at least you've been told you
don't have much of a sense about humors
this item is used on combat the snake
spleen steak liver they call this the
liver because snakes need it in order to
live ah great well I guess I don't need
the varmint knife equipped to be able to
snake skin things all right well then
did that that's great well so what's
with this big slab might be able to try
to push it over that would have been
smart to do a little bit ago that would
have been smart about the football or
wood what is that thing good question
what is
[Music]
aliens are we dealing with aliens this
looks dangerous what a monolith is dark
Oh looks like there was a huge cave in
at some point
weird device I got a strange stone arrow
okey-dokey then
[Music]
all this is okay oh there I go
we got a strange device what does it do
triangular object made out of a strange
stone like material shot with channels
of smooth black glass okay all right
well don't know what to do about that
don't know why they do about that let me
go to my original destination because I
don't know what the humming gave is all
about I gotta go to the silver plate er
hopefully get something good at it hey
how's it going all right partner the
sign is too reading it says silver plate
er this guy covers things with silver to
make them well silver oh oh can man make
Garry silver that would be expensive man
I'm guessing it would probably kill you
ah no good that that is that indeed hey
buddy
pally what can I do you for what do you
have on the menu through the menu what
are you talking about isn't this a
walk-up style restaurant but no I'm a
silver plate or a plate things with
silver you know oh I thought your son
was never mind the man grins revealing a
full set of silver plated teeth so you
need something plated one of my options
he looks you up and down I could play
with that hat you're wearing people with
the silver hats get more done they say
this will enchant your hat to add one to
your maximum action points
maybe something else you can play your
melee weapon you're using there it'll do
more damage that way more damage by
three maybe something else play your
pistol alright maybe something else he
looks at your back and mouth hmm turn it
look an interesting challenge that's a
fine-looking tongue you got
[Laughter]
my actual tongue the one in my head what
would that do for me I'll come back to
you about that one I guess I'd have a
silver tongue maybe it increased my
dhikr and ability but I you know I'm not
not 100% sure about that that's that's
weird
also why do you want to plate my didn't
eat it I guess
alright strange stone arrow you found it
starts going crazy beeping in pooping
and whirling around of its own accord it
practically drags you in the direction
of a strange decrepit looking house
guess I'm going to this house then the
perfect serves house the beeping machine
leads you to a ramshackle house in the
middle of a desert alright okay Tim
Fleur you calm down there it's your
partner ah a house where the beeping
blocks is living it must in a manner of
speaking I guess alright ah
alrighty then books are so boring it's a
wonder the Shelf isn't full of holes I
get it this appears to be an extremely
powerful magnifying mirror basically an
inside-out microscope check yourself out
the microscopic mites that live in your
eyelashes seem to be getting along just
fine great professors toilet isn't very
good repair no it's fun glad I flushed
that great map ante with circles and
lines excuse me my name's mum Fleur
thumper dink what oh I didn't notice you
coming I'm not used to visitors but
folks generally call me the professor
isn't something I can do for you alright
found this bleeping gizmo and I sort of
followed the bleeping and it led me here
well I'll be it certainly led you to the
right place young man this is El
vibrator technology and I happen to be
as much an expert as anyone alive today
Oh what now hell's a burrito they were
an ancient race it lived here long
before humans
well they mostly lived on the ground so
they might as still be living as far as
I know never seen a peep of an actual
person though just the machines they
left but
with a space aliens could be aliens or
genius pre humans or an entirely
different terrestrial evolutionary line
at this stage of investigation it's
impossible to say this exciting let me
have a go to look at your bleeping gizmo
as I suspected this is one of the
transponders it detects other elf abraao
technology in homes in you see that's
why it's led you here I've got a thing
I've been trying to repair you think us
around with the transponder for a bit
and then plug the strange stone marble
into the socket in it there you go
good as new just swipe up or down turn
it on or off swipe now I gotta warn you
this device will lead you to abandon del
vibrator technology but it might also
attract unwanted attention from what
from the bride of technology you'll see
what I mean just be careful okay you
know nothing to think about it you've
arrived at a perfect time in order to
get anywhere further with my research I
need more samples of El vibrator tip but
searching eats up all the time I could
be using for researching it I get you
right you're the adventurer sometime
you'll bring me back whatever devices
you find it if I can get them back up
and running that'll benefit both of us
all right deal great third priority will
be getting the Keystone fabricator
running they lock the doors with these
things in little stone alloy blocks see
if we can make our own that'll open a
lot of doors for us literally and
figuratively all right what do you need
the components aren't rare it releases
fast priceless alien technology goes
bring me down not five handfuls of scrap
I should be able to salvage the last
parts venue from that much Roger that
okay these books are all about concepts
to advanced for you to even recognize Oh
things such at various things you said
it yes this guy doesn't sleep very much
better contains exactly ten instances of
the exact same shirt and 20 identical
sacs this is a professor's Keystone
fabricator he's waiting on some parts to
finish it hint and okay tokens the hint
I did I don't know why but I'm gonna go
to my destination
that's for doll bed I'm gonna go to for
doll then you find the liquor cabinet in
woods maybe there used to be a house
around it try opening it behind it
locked I need those I don't have as many
locks as I need so I'm gonna leave it
because I need it
oh I need to take a pic down to the
other fort before I go down here that's
what it was I remember fort cowardice
whoa okay monster oh well it's dead all
right well I got scrap that's good well
that makes my life a lot easier if they
just come to me all right let's go
I guess tumble it away all right let's
see if we can open this goddamn door
boink all right going in oh hi oh yeah
how are you
I shouldn't open this pie safe whoa what
hey buddy boo buddy bumbly boo the
Goblet is seated at this desk is
repeatedly firing his pistol at that
high safe hello what are you doing
shooting pies always always shooting
pies could you elaborate on that
why is shooting a pie yes - destroying
obviously must - destroying a terrible
pie what is wrong with a pie bah
human will never understand it ask again
no really why up high shooting shut up
so much angry keep trying look I'm
pretty sure the pie being a pie is
destroyed destoroyah huh look so many
holes in a pie safe you winning a pie is
dead you certain being waiting here I
will check oh yeah
big through the bullet holes yep that
Paro was shot tell all right got that
pray you are success a pie is so very
destroyed being I I doing it so much
doing it but now what huh
what I shooting now I guess you finding
another pie but they're more pies being
yes a world is full of pies oh no this
violin Singh will never ending sorry
being not wishing to enabling this
behavior no this is my cross pepper I
must go in continuing the flight okay
thank you
you okay I wish you good luck don't know
why I'm gonna intimidate you but here I
go wait leaving a hat here it will not
be safe being you yes good you
protecting a hat for me all right
general gob yes I'm the general now
that's that's nice Dane's memories of
violence and more recent memories of
violence against pie specifically who
would do like that oh I do like that hat
ooh I do like that hat I don't have any
spells but yeah that might be good but I
think I do have another somewhere here
ooh wait I forgot I had this give me
this whew thick-skinned Gore on it so
attack up an entire row that's good I'm
gonna do that hell yeah unfortunately
you accidentally Gore the book into
piece of wall practices what'd you learn
[ __ ] did me to do that all right let me
see but where's mesquite good I know I
have snake skin somewhere here I've only
got coal snake skin which increases
Moxie which is better for shooting so
sure I guess that makes sense
all right there we go all right I got
some moxie I like my hat I like it I
like this hat
that's good hat but I miss my old hat oh
damn it why must I be cursed with so
many cool bats now i'ma go for general
gobs hat that's good hat I like that BAM
it's good I would be old and in with the
new I always say all right we need to go
all the way back up to this fort now cuz
I was totally worth going dude I'm gonna
go to the railroad camp soon Oh dig if
we got well that's nice all right just
sell them I've got a whole lot of things
that I promised you just sell but I
gotta hit the trail and get up there all
right for it all dead you come with me
oh they are all dead should've known
that wow wow wow
he has a little intent where did all
their skins go well that's up that's a
question definitely right well hello he
doesn't seem to know as you beg your
pardon
excuse me pardon excuse me scuse me I'm
so sorry about this excuse me alright
hey what do we got here vamp the region
table is little model of the region
Turrell it's flush flush oh no I can't
what's that one oh whoa wait that's
awesome who's that
hey I saw that riflemen insignia pin
what does that do
help me shoot better oh cool but I like
my revolting brooch is there a latrine
here if I want me to dig around in
nobody anybody at all now
all right well open that one all right
full canteen
what's it full of puts out fires okay
all right then that's good to know I can
lock him out at lunch oh well I got a
needle over there when smelling salts
golden bones gold chips all right well
there's anyone they give me this stuff
that I need a lot of things right there
and there this place is great because
I'm a [ __ ] for it supplies pick up a can
at random we blew the label smoke
dandruff and syrup nauseating dehydrated
grubs salty skin mushy hair oil lye
treated eyeballs candy blends robes of
spiders and oil pureed spiders in syrup
sugar dandruff jelly bat wings there
sure is a lot of good stuff here well
nothing of value I gasps all right sure
I'm out of here good [ __ ] Scooby
what's the point of this what's the
point of it dig through no way not
without some stench resistance rats what
about my flowers don't I have flowers
don't I have flowers that flowers don't
yes sweet-smelling flowers yeah oh
patrol cap oh that one's good too oh I
like it yeah oh that ain't as good as
general gob
I like general gob oh this is bizarre
why is this here somebody left their
knapsack on a burn scroll it's also an
evil looking leather-bound toe okay if
you're doctoring nextmax
last things a little diary which you
decide to leave in their kc owner comes
back I'm gonna read it seems to have
been written by one of the necromancers
cultists he and several others were
reading the dead soldiers here on the
theory that the best undead army would
be literally an undead army the hits in
the plan came when they raised the
officers who decided they weren't going
to take orders from a bunch of weirdo
civilians the last entry suggests the
author and his cohorts were planning and
sacking the abandoned or planning on
abandoning their a station and reporting
back to the necromancer but the entry
abruptly in the middle of the sentence
but a hum hum okay well put that in
there gives you the grinning skull skill
was that seems like it's probably
dangerous are you sure you want to read
it I probably shouldn't read that maybe
Rover see you found it will let you
determine with the most of the mountains
hmm
he'll cow energy all right well I'm
getting somewhere
her name no name pepperoni oh it's mass
grave is absolutely teeming with the
fruitful Minh they don't seem to be
interested in getting out but you could
definitely jump in there if you were
itching for a fight
there's one wandering in the end of the
pit nearest you I'll go in what the hell
dude beefed up and I'm gonna get yo lap
get Kraft geez well there goes Gary well
there goes you too right man I got a I
got a beef up Gary Gary is not as beefy
as he could be
I really want to learn this though
[Music]
seems like it's probably pretty
dangerous are you sure you want to read
it
now we'll leave that alone probably for
the best
yeah you guys can tell me whether that's
a good idea or not all right let's go
this circus it's going on here looks
like you found the circus those clowns
we're talking about a circus that's like
a clown hive fortunately it's not a very
big circus there probably aren't very
many clowns certainly not enough for an
army or invasion force or anything
still as it turns out do not mind clowns
are a real thing any number of them
could be real trouble you walk up as
nonchalantly as possible so the clown
man in clowning suspect you know is
horrible secret when is whistle
innocently doodly-doo Oh white face not
man's and probably a whole lot of them
not a safe place for going no but we
probably ought to try why why do we
probably ought to try northern clown
word is your approach the clown puts on
a basically cheerful facial expression
that retail employees use when the last
thing they want to do is deal with the
customer but they're not allowed to say
so doctor
welcome to Barnaby Bob's perfectly
normal traveling circus sideshow sir how
can I help you I'd like to run away with
the circus please aren't you a little
too old for that sorry we're not hiring
okay let's stop like to see the circus
well you came to the right place in but
if you want to get inside you'll need a
ticket yeah I just so happen to have one
the clown looks very surprised what okay
good freeze sir huh I'll just take that
and stamp your hand for re-entry there
we go
enjoy the show what about my partner
partners get in free
thanks thank you
here we go as you enter the circus the
ticket boosts clowns shouts walking to
the circus actually I guess is more of a
carnival but let's not split hairs as
nonchalantly as possible there are bunch
of clouds around working at the boost
and so on we're clowns and customers of
which there doesn't seem to be more than
a dozen or so which is good and that it
means the clown's can't disappear you as
easily if they figure out what you know
but on the
and things go wrong here innocent
bystanders might get caught in the
crossfire got it got it condemned until
further notice we encourage anyone
suffering from horse bites to consult
the doctor snooping around
howdy fella can I interest you in the
wondrous and mysterious delights of a
sideshow down there secrets mysteries
things too weird and disturbing to be
witnessed by the light of day
freaks not just freaks gosh how much
does it cost for you 300 made for
everyone else
you won't be disappointed in the event
you are disappointed no refunds there we
go well the sideshow tent is fairly
large and packed with weird things to
look at like all good shows are a few
lanterns are hanging from the ceiling
castering flickering shadows around to
making everyone look even more eerie
clown is hanging out near presumably to
keep an eye on the exhibits he grins and
nods as you enter good look around just
remember no touching okay someone old
weird bent mirrors to make you look all
crazy as if there wasn't enough
crazy-looking stuff around here already
look at yourself yeah this mirror
somehow shows you what it looked like in
clown makeup bloodshot eyes stare back
he from a pasty Whiteface painted with
an odd pattern of red triangles if the
flickering Lantern light it almost looks
like he would see you alright
makes you look stretched out and fan
your limbs twist and writhe like snakes
as you move around it's a bit unsettling
and your muscles ache a little
sympathetically alright
short squashed looking folded up like an
accordion you spend a moment moving back
and forth in front of the mirror seeing
how it changes kind of amusing well down
to the left we have our collection of
spooky warped mirrors right here we have
our exhibited clown eggs and pickled
punks and further down to the right is
our freak show
feel free to explore and I'll be here if
you have any questions I got a question
what's with those mirrors they're right
they call it an optical illusion is it
has to do with the way the layer of legs
off of them I'm under presenter than
what I saw can't be explained by the
reflection of life no telling what you
might see if you look too long yeah
closer look
cloud eggs and the circus community is
traditional for each clown to paint
their chosen makeup pattern onto an
eggshell the cloud eggs are archived for
future reference to ensure that no one
chooses a pattern has already been used
is considered extremely taboo to wear
the clown's look let's face this must be
the eggs for the clown's that work in
the circus you recognize a few of them
like the clown here in the sideshow 10
the ticket seller out front is that you
lead a little closer to inspect the jars
they mostly contain malformed and/or
mutated animals pickled in formaldehyde
a three-headed kitten some kind of
ferret or a weasel with eight legs a
twisted Mobius loop of snake without a
head or tail weird crazy stuff one shell
seems to bonded to huge gross pail grubs
like fat featureless white worms the
size of a sweet potato the one on the
end is larger than the others and has
shiny black eyes someone has painted his
face with an apparent parody of a clown
makeup closer look Pacey weifare has
been painted with little blue triangles
over and under the eyes Kuchar has been
a long thin slash of a mouth and well
and the area around has been painted
with bright red lipstick the black eyes
flash red is the thing suddenly thrashes
in his jar spinning to face you and
stretching his mouth wide open revealing
rows of yellow shark teeth you stumbled
back with a craft shock yeah that's
pretty good
what is that Dana real critters made a
rubber and clay and doll parts and such
got an electromagnet under the shelf to
move it with he pushes a little gizmo
out of his pocket to show you should've
seen your face you've got jump right out
of your boots
[Music]
all right then hello this guy's
startling sight even for a circus freak
shows entire head is one enormous eye
bruh eyeball as he look him over he
stares back to you now that he's got
much of a choice
hello there a mum Fleur how's it going
can you talk yes not alright you'd move
a little to the side maligne over the
rope to get it close to look at the guy
he's basically just what he seems to be
guy with a giant eyeball for a head you
do notice two things so first he has an
odd lump ik foot will you'd call base of
his skull if he had one sort of crumpled
fleshy mass the size of a fist with a
squint and some imagination it almost
looks like a crushed shriveled vestigial
remains of a human hand the second thing
you notice is that his ankles are locked
to the select of his stool and the
stools are bolted to the floor hey blank
circus gag is he and slowly curling two
fists and the knuckles turn white with
the tension okay alrighty then man is
neatly dressed those suit is a bit
threadbare and out of fashion he's
smoking a pipe and living through a
magazine when you stop to look at him he
nods I believe hello there welcome to
the sideshow my name is Douglas hi I'm
um Fleur ledee to meet you so what's
your deal why am I in a sideshow you
mean yeah you seem perfectly normal
a fourth right of you of course it is
only natural to wonder wait a minute you
said that last bit without moving your
lips are you a ventriloquist not at all
allow me to demonstrate he stands up and
turns around his back as the same as his
front that is his suit has been tailored
for two front sides and he has another
face on the back of his hand ooh his
hair cut and parted appropriately as he
sits back down his knees and other
joints crack and pop loudly as they
reverse themselves
Douglas winces slightly though certainly
not as much as you'd expect that's
horrifying
surprising yes a bit yeah how is that
even possible
Douglas shrugs and oldest pipe up to the
now back of his head so the other face
can take a puff for you
Siamese twins not exactly it's difficult
to describe I'm afraid do minds in one
body with two faces it'll be closer to
the truth to save two instances of
same mind with as you say two phases
you're right that doesn't make any sense
at all other face chuckles and Douglas
holds his magazine behind his back took
some getting used to that much is quite
certain were you born like this
I would rather not discuss how it came
to be this way if you don't mind okay
sorry
your knees must be a rack surgery was
necessary to permit them to bend in both
directions it sounds worse than it feels
I assure you why are you in a sideshow
with a regular student haircut you could
pass for normal I have a contract the
corner of you eye you spot the clown
making a gesture but you didn't catch
what it was Douglas clears his throat
Plus well it's quite the life you know
free room and board travel the world and
you meet interesting people there's a
lady here with their head sticking out
of a hole in large metal box she nods
politely hello well it's interesting
yeah I'm sure it is ask you a question
certainly why are you in a box first
things first we haven't been introduced
yet Oh mum Fleur nice to meet you
nice to meet you mum Fleur I'm Janet hi
dad it's uh why are you in a box that's
a rather personal question isn't it I'm
sorry I'm only teasing dear would you
like to see inside it's awfully forward
sure and it whistles to the signal to
cloudy moseys over he unlocks a box
throws it open with a theatrical
flourish inside instead of Jana's body
you see a tangled complicated
conservative glass tubes ticking
clockwork cares pumps liquids of various
colors mostly rents lost through the
tubes what do you think that's
horrifying like something out of a
nightmare yes that's an accurate
description I'm sorry I hope I haven't
insulted you no no offense taken I've
only seen it myself once in a mirror to
quite a water okay you still examine
what well weird gross
indeed educational and is topical
hookman what does that do how this
happened yeah it's some kind of terrible
accident I'm sorry but I can't talk
about that oh of course sorry it must be
a painful memory
calmly compose faces creases into a very
slight grimaces she shoots a sidelong
glance
clown yes well nice to meet you Janet
whoa
that is horrifying what's up with all
this [ __ ] huh
about those people you mean the freaks
ain't they a scream the one with the
giant eyeball head my favorite nice
fella
quiet fella if you have a question about
the other do feel for you to ask them
personally I wouldn't want to be telling
tales out of school since the I guy
can't talk he can ask me about him okay
what can you tell me about him
not much I'm afraid to be honest he
joined us about a year ago maybe less
where'd he come from looks like yeah you
know write about him on all the papers
right well yeah it sure is mysterious
how'd I get like that couldn't tell you
I bet you've got a theory at least yeah
well maybe he saw something no fear
human folk scene why does he log to his
chair ah you noticed that didn't you
real shame that his fellows a bit
unpredictable has a violent spell once
in a while gosh oh you worry not I've
given an eye on him oh boy I got a
question about the eggs that's a
traditional clown thing there's a
placard next to there explains the
details dog dad to Klaus what are the
things in the jar that's what we in the
business call pickled Punk's a menagerie
is strange and twisted creatures such as
you've never seen before captured and
preserved an on display for your
entertainment identification that's how
the boss says but the real as real as
they come I was not worth 300 meters sit
in a toy balloon how do you make him
float
there's nothing to it heck they all
float around here how much are they
cause yeah they're all right I'll take
one okay all right got a balloon I don't
know what a balloons gonna do for you
it's red okay well that's great what can
you tell me about this reel it's more of
a carnival but let's not split hairs
what would you like no what are you
traveling plans out of the way that's
why we set down here someone more rural
keeps things relatively quiet what would
scout around get the lay of the land and
all would you travel from always your
previous stop interesting
Oh Northwest - it's a little hole in the
ground kind of a place you would've
heard of all right why is everyone here
clown ass additional when what do you
call them rodeo stop being put on the
rodeo clowns took other jobs at the
circuses and carnivals
over the years it just became the normal
thing for Kearney's to be clowns it's a
community you might say yeah who's this
Barnaby Bob guy oh the boys is a real
famous showman oh I'm not surprised you
wouldn't have heard of him around here
I'm not like a hawk and he's a real whiz
with those knives of his dumb mrs. judge
the real highlight of the carnival okay
don't like any of this any of this at
all oh test my aim all right game for
the sharp eyes and quick reflexes
where's the game all by me I got a bunch
of thick-skinned daughter inflated
balloons for 10:00 meet a loony a cheap
and accurate pistol and a file of badly
made ammunition - your goal is - Papa's
Mayo's balloons as you can't before the
pistol stop working it's an usually on a
sounding description I've discovered
making the challenge sound exactly as
difficult as it is only makes people
more determined to be the one who beats
it well it surprised the ticket to
Barnaby Bob strange which is otherwise
sold out so it's a rare catch my friend
I'll give it a shot all right shoot
shoot backwards and cross-eyed just the
way I like Miami foam you into the
pistol and fire until it's empty at
which point you can't figure out how to
get it back open to put more in Wow not
a single balloon Bob that did tell you
the rules right how popping the balloons
is the actual go hole let's try that
again there we go I'll give it a shot
shoot from the hip you shoot at the
balloons and bill the pistol jams you
manage to pop a few but not very many
knots about average but not enough to
win the prize
alright then just my mind oh I get it
ah I get it okay so alright what's the
prize Barnaby Bob I got it carefully
scan the deck of cards clowns present
ready
I'll give it just a little bit just so
it's just a little bit
Oh Klan starts picking cards out of the
deck and holding them up with the backs
to you
you don't even manage to guess a single
one of them fact you can't even remember
what the flag that looks like [ __ ] do
this give it a lot as you guess a few
all right whatever
oh hi it's Katie Orr searching around
with a sad look on his face you okay you
lose your parents lost my lucky bottle
cap you haven't seen it have you sir no
ball keeping my eye out trying to steal
a little chain alright fine man whatever
hello is a clown here selling rubber toy
balloons waiters it the same clown fur
before he looks identical is he followed
me around hi fella anything else I can
do for you huh no that's the other
balloon guy we just dress alike and use
the same face paint did we fool you it's
a sin to use the same face paint I know
that I know Ben alright what about your
circus who's this Barnaby Bob guy I've
already a set okay okay well that's my
mind okay
how about I do this I get it I'll give
it a shot I got I gonna hit it quite
hard oh that was very close not a grand
prize winner but it's the best thing
I've seen today so it's got to be worth
something small plush bear that's nice
how high it's Mike oh oh I'm very close
wait point point point ah
I'm strong enough now baby hey you want
me to give me one of these
hey extremely hard you pick them out
toss it end over and catch you a couple
times to test its way casually slam it
into the lever well I'll be
that's some genuine muscle you've got on
you fella no you got a circus show to
you sure we'll be starting soon don't
you miss it oh very good scoop over yo
but sadly this will have to wait until
the next episode I'm all that time for
this one so thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know how to do in
the comments below and get ready first
oh I don't like any other in the next
episode and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]